in this video I want to talk a little
bit about at words so let me write down
at so a tea and at itself is an at word
for example someone might ask you where
are you at at a goes at t2 at where are
you at
and you might say I am at I am at the
movies now let's think about all of the
at words and it's not going to be all of
them we're I'm going to do my best
attempt to do most of them so if someone
were to ask you what is this animal what
is this animal right over there you
might say oh that that's a bat that is a
bat so once again let me start with it's
going to start with the letter B and
then it's going to have the at
afterwards so it's B the sound B makes
is but ba bat so be a be a T bat that's
what this is here and I'll sound it out
one more time but Bubba
that's what B tells us B is the buh buh
buh sound Bubba at a is a T is too but
at bat and that's what we have right
over here we have ourselves a bat now
this creature might look this animal
might look familiar it is a cat and once
again it is another at word and it
starts with C C for cut cut cat so let
me write it down so this is a cat C C is
cut cut cut ah at cat at at cat and
that's a cat right over there
now why do I have this picture right
over here because one of these two mice
is fat and fat is another at word so
once again this mouse right over here
this mouse right over here is fat fuh
fuh-fuh at fafa 4 f goes buffa ah too
fat this mouse right here is fat
this one isn't so fat [ __ ] ah fat now
what if I were to draw let me draw
something and I think you might know
what I'm about to draw what if I had
something that looked like this so it
looks like this let me try it to draw it
is ease well as possible make it up a
little thing over here as well now this
I'm going to put on top of someone's
head so let me draw the individual whose
head it's on top of and so if someone
asked you what is this thing in orange
that I've drawn right over here most
people would call this thing a hat a hat
and it starts with H the sound H makes
us ha ha ha H for huh ha ha ha at H huh
ah two hat and that's this right over
here this is that is a hat now you might
be saying is this what is this a picture
of is this a picture of a mouse or maybe
a squirrel and you really can't tell
because you can't see his tail but this
is a rat and so once again rat starts
with the rough sound the rough sound is
rr4 rah rah rah rah rah ah rat rat
that's a rat right over there now what
about what about if you have a a door
let me draw a door I'll draw an orange
door so let's draw a door over here and
maybe let me draw a the doorknob right
over here and let's say that this is the
front door let me color it in a little
bit let's say that this is a front door
and then
onto the front in front of that door in
order for people to clean their shoes we
will put a doormat
a door mat begins with mm4 mama mama mat
so this is a I'll do it in that orange
color this is a mat m4 ma-ma-ma-ma-ma ah
to Matt Matt Matt and well there's
actually a few more I thought where I
was almost done was actually a few more
AK words if I were to if I said that
this was a picture of someone let's say
that this is a chair right over here and
someone was sitting there so this is my
simple drawing of someone sitting down
if someone was sitting down on that
chair you might say we're weird where
have they sat so this right here they
sat if someone sat in the past you would
say sat s4c sosa ah Sat and if someone
were to take their hand and very nicely
place it on their back and and make them
feel good about themselves you might say
that they're giving them a pat if
someone Pat's you on the back so that is
pup-pup at Papa ah - so let's review all
of these at words I don't know if I got
them all but I try to do my best
first of all at itself is an outward
at-at then this animal right over here
this creature we call this a bat but at
bat this this cute and fluffy thing is a
cat it's a white cat at this over here
is a hat it's an orange hat hahaha at
hat this mouse this cute and fluffy
mouse is
fat [ __ ] foot foot at feh at and we said
this is where he sat suck at sat sat and
then we gave him a pat but act pat and
then finally this thing here was not a
squirrel or a mouse it was a rat rat rat